cardio
[Music]
it's
[Music]
not
[Music]
boring
so yeah cardio is not boring guys
a lot of people think that it is and
that's probably because when they think
of cardio all they think of is running
or cycling on a stationary bike or
something like that these things can be
fairly boring although i actually quite
enjoy running especially if i'm
exploring new places point is a lot of
people get on a lot better with what we
classically consider to be metabolic
conditioning exercises things like
battle ropes heavy bag tyre flip
metaball slams skipping all these things
will burn calories they'll strengthen
your heart improve circulation give you
all the benefits that you want from you
know regular bout of cardio but at the
same time they're going to help preserve
and even build muscle they're going to
improve your work capacity and they can
be a lot more fun and a lot more
cathartic a lot of people just don't
consider that this stuff is an option or
that it's available to them so in this
video i'm going to discuss some of the
very best metabolic conditioning
exercises i'm going to talk about what
their unique benefits are and we're
going to explore how to integrate them
into your workouts
i'm actually going to start with an
exercise that not everyone was going to
have access to but anyway the following
exercises on this list are going to be
much more available to people i'm
talking of course about the tyre flip
which recently this nearby field of mine
someone's just dumped loads of tires
here so it's awesome for me we're going
to do is get down low as if you were
dead lifting then you're going to hoist
the thing up by hinging at the hips
pushing through the legs at the same
time you're going to curl with your
biceps then when it gets to the top
you're going to push it over nice thing
about this right away is it's a pulling
movement and a pushing movement the push
isn't as intense as the pull but when
you get to that top position you've got
to push it over you're still going to
eventually feel it if you're doing it
for high reps which is something that
you can do of course it's a hip hinge of
course it's good for the legs as well
this makes it a form of resistance
cardio as are most of the things i'm
going to cover on this list and
resistance cardio is great because on
the whole it spares muscles perfect to
put at the end of a workout as a kind of
cardio finisher
the other great thing about this move is
that it's concentric only what this
means is that for the biceps in
particular you're shortening you're
curling but you're never using the
eccentric portion and lengthening whilst
a lot of people praise the eccentric
portions of movement for building more
muscle for building more strength it's
also the most fatiguing this is what
causes the most muscle damage so you
take the longest to recover from it
because you're not luring the weight at
all here with your biceps that means you
can perform this over and over again
without needing as long to recover for
the biceps this in turn makes a
fantastic way to get blood flowing to
the biceps particularly if you've just
done a workout that targets the biceps
which can encourage more growth over
time this is something that ross edgely
talks about he has huge biceps and he
used this exercise among others when
training for his extremely impressive
rope climbing feet where he climbed like
the distance of mount everest or
something like that i think the fact
that you're picking up the tyre from the
ground rather than lifting it from a
raised position on top of two plates
means you have to squat and hinge down
further than you would do for a deadlift
at the same time the fact that you're
not actually lifting the whole way to
any point means that it's relatively
safe to use for higher rep ranges of
course though you need to listen to your
body you just start with a light weight
and you need to decide whether your
focus is more on strength or
conditioning
now to go from something that not
everyone has access to to something that
i think nearly everybody can use next up
is skipping so i made a video recently
on the benefits of skipping so i won't
go into huge detail now suffice to say
that skipping not only burns loads of
calories and these are equivalent or
greater to running you can get a really
good calorie burn in just 10 minutes but
at the same time they're brilliant for
working on your hand-eye coordination
your timing your rhythm training your
brain because of course you need to jump
over the rope you need to time that jump
and at the same time if you're
practicing and learning cool tricks then
it makes it far more engaging this makes
it immediately more fun but at the same
time puts your brain in a more plastic
state because when we're learning that's
when our training is truly effective
at the same time this builds ankle
stiffness giving you that rebound
ability when you're sprinting and it
teaches you to be light on your feet
which is absolutely fantastic for
martial artists boxers etc i can only
basically skip i'm not a fantastic
skipper i made a whole video on it and
i'm not a great skipper that's the
audacity of the bioneer check out grant
stevens if you want to see someone who
really knows how to skip that said i
learned the basic skip really really
easily and the rest is just bonus the
rest is just fun stuff to work on
skipping is something that you can do
anywhere it's really easy to fit a
skipping rope into a bag and that brings
me nicely to today's sponsor cross rope
so cross rope makes skipping ropes
specifically weighted skipping ropes not
necessarily like super heavy skipping
ropes which is a thing as well but we're
talking like in some cases a quarter of
a pound up to like two pounds and what
these can do is add that little bit of
extra resistance when you're skipping so
you're getting a bit of an upper body
workout at the same time in particular
it's great for the shoulders great for
the forearms however what it also does
is it changes some of the other
properties of the rope such that it
changes the speed of the rope for
example and this is really cool for
people who are learning tricks because
this rope for example this is half a
pound and when i put this on it slowed
it down just enough that it gave me that
extra control and that way i can much
better learn moves like the crossover
like the side swipe like the double
under and these are things i've tried
and really struggled with in the past
with faster ropes but this is perfect on
the other hand really big heavyweights
make it difficult as well because it's
hard to move them at the right speed so
you can find the perfect rope for you
and they're just really really well made
and a great thing about it is that when
you want to change the rope you can just
clip it in
and out
like that i mean when i saw that to be
honest i was sold
the ropes are also super durable they're
made of a steel cable and then this is
wrapped in a propriety material of some
sort basically means don't need to worry
about them degrading over time if you're
skipping on concrete they also don't get
all tangled up like a lot of ropes do
and you get access to the crossroad app
which will guide you through workouts
help track your progress and generally
ensure that you get the results you want
so you're not just skipping aimlessly
there's also a 60-day money-back
guarantee so if you're not sure if
you're going to be able to learn to skip
or you're not sure if you're going to
like it then you can try them you can
literally use them every day for those
60 days and send it back if you don't
like it and if you order now and use the
link in the description down below and
the promo code bioneer you'll also get
15 off of any of the most popular sets
on their site
so next up for you we have battle ropes
so battle ropes essentially are two big
heavy ropes that you slam against the
ground sometimes using alternating arms
sometimes bilaterally this is not only a
great form of catharsis to vent some
steam it's also a brilliant form of
cardio for burning calories that also
challenges your muscles and the great
thing about this is it challenges in
particular the muscles of the upper body
when we think about cardio we think of
cycling running jogging all these things
focus a lot on the legs so to be able to
get the same cardio for the upper body
is actually really good and especially
when you consider that endurance and
cardio they are domain specific so you
can build more mitochondria in your
biceps in your shoulders so by using
conditioning in these areas you'll be
able to improve your work capacity and
your performance when it comes to things
that utilize your upper body such as
martial arts training for example so you
just train the shoulders you create lots
of muscle damage now you're sending
loads of blood there to really encourage
recovery and growth
[Music]
next up is heavy bag training in other
words bag workouts punching kicking
hitting a bag i highly highly recommend
that everybody try this form of training
even if you're a non-martial artist a
lot of people think that you know
hitting a punching bag or even just
shadow boxing is only for martial
artists but i don't think this could be
further from the truth it's a fantastic
form of cardio it's full body using your
upper body and your legs you're bouncing
around it's a real tough cardio workout
but at the same time it gives you lots
to be engaged with it's cathartic again
it's good fun at the same time you can
work on your technique if you record
yourself and play it back i'm not great
at hitting a bag i've got lots of issues
with my technique still and it's
something i'm always working on and
whilst it's not a big focus of my
training it's something i really enjoy
and getting feedback from you guys and
watching myself slightly improve over
time again it just makes training a lot
more enjoyable if you're someone who
gets bored running on a treadmill and
try hitting a heavy bag instead you'll
get all of the cardio benefits plus it's
resistance cardio again so you're also
building muscle if you're someone who
finds running on a treadmill boring then
hitting a punch bag couldn't be further
from that and plus it's resistance
cardio again so you're building up your
shoulders your pecs your triceps even
your lats because you need to be able to
pull that punch pull that arm back
quickly you're building a rotational
strength so many workout programs lack
anything for rotational strength in the
transverse plane this is why i recommend
things like shot at throws with a
medicine ball or wood choppers but if
you're kicking a heavy bag using a
roundhouse kick this is a massively
rotational movement and in fact punching
is a rotational movement so it's
fantastic for building strong obliques
and for learning to move quickly and
powerfully in that really important
plane that we use all the time in our
daily lives
another fantastic option is the
kettlebell swing and i just made a
massive video on kettlebell swings won't
go into it in a lot of detail right now
the kettlebell swings are a fantastic
form of endurance cardio that really
build powerful glutes hamstrings the
whole posterior chain they build a
stronger back they help to jump higher
run faster and this is what has led to
them sometimes being described as having
the what the hell effect because they
improve so much stuff they make people
go what the hell
kettlebell swings also just a really
convenient exercise you can do anywhere
just pick up a kettlebell start doing
swings it does take a little bit of time
to get the technique right you want to
make sure you're really engaging the
glutes and not driving from your back or
swinging up with your arms but once you
do this they can have all those amazing
benefits you can use more of a hard
style swing we're exploding from the
hips really thrusting forwards and
swinging that weight up and then waiting
until it comes back down and catching it
again
organ is a sports style swing where you
kind of use a pendulum motioner let the
weight guide you so that you're putting
in less work and this allows you to do
higher rep ranges by allowing you to do
longer sets this type of kettlebell
swings actually superior probably for
metabolic conditioning specifically but
i personally prefer to use a more hard
style esque version by the way using
kettlebell swing at the end of your
workouts is a great way to get the blood
flowing to burn calories to improve your
endurance and work capacity but at the
same time to improve your jump height
and to build stronger glutes
i've also talked at length about med
ball slams these are also fantastic for
metabolic conditioning like skipping
like heavy bag work medical slams are
actually really fun you just slam the
ball down into the ground let it bounce
back up catch it and repeat the process
over and over again feels very cathartic
so i just accidentally reversed my car
into a bollard when dropping my daughter
off at preschool wasn't a huge dent but
it cracked the paint and whilst the car
wasn't brand new is the nicest car that
i've ever owned and i only got it a few
months ago
and in terms of biomechanic it's
actually the opposite of an explosive
vertical jump instead of being a triple
extension it's more of a triple flexion
as you collapse the body this is what
you want to focus on bring yourself down
at the waist as though you're doing the
counter movement ready to jump and then
you slam the ball down at the same time
it also really works the lat
surprisingly
there are lots of variations that you
can do with a med ball slam and i made a
whole video on it once again so go and
check that out if you're interested
as someone who also talks about the
brain on the channel i feel like i
should mention this point that catharsis
doesn't actually work according to the
research
finally that brings me to one of my
favorite protocols and that's to do high
repetition push-ups you've seen me do
this loads of times on the channel
basically i do these really high rep
explosive bouncy push-ups which don't
include a full range of motion or
particularly much control it's more
about pumping out rep after rep whilst
there's definitely a time and a place
for controlled full range of motion
push-up and i'm not saying you shouldn't
do that there's also time and place for
this kind of push-up because it's
fantastic for flooding the muscles with
metabolites and blood which is great for
hypertrophy if you've only got access to
your body weight you want to build big
pecs then this can be really good as
long as you maintain that continuous
time and attention at the same time
makes you explosive and bouncy and
powerful in that area and when you get
to those higher rep ranges like the
hundreds hundreds and fifties then
you're actually getting a good cardio
workout a good conditioning workout at
the same time perfect if you're just on
a push day or a peck day if you want to
end on something that's going to really
flood the area with blood i also like to
mix and match my push-ups you've seen me
do this too i like to throw in different
moves whether it's a kick through
whether it's a burpee whether it's an
explosive jumping push-up whether it's a
hazard spring and by combining these all
together in these explosive flows makes
the movement a lot more interesting it
might also have benefits for the brain
and for learning in general because it
benefits from the interference principle
and by mixing things up it's just more
of an engaging challenge you can
actually express yourself and be more
creative
so those are some of my favorite picks
when it comes to metabolic conditioning
workouts some of the best ways to end a
workout if you want to get a cardio
finisher in there some of the best ways
to improve your endurance and your work
capacity and your vo2 max and all that
good stuff of course you can always
combine all these things and make a
metcon circuit this way not only are you
mixing things up even more making it
more fun and more interesting you're
also targeting all the different muscle
groups and you're going to get the blood
flowing around the body more because you
have this shunting effect where the
blood has to pull first in the upper
body when you're doing your battle ropes
and your punches and then down to the
lower body when you're doing things like
kettlebell swings or skipping and by
doing this your heart works harder you
burn more calories and you improve your
overall circulation and your ability to
exert yourself in lots of different ways
as we know life doesn't throw things at
us in these kind of convenient sets and
reps we don't have blocks of just push
day we have a mixture of things coming
at us all the time we need to be able to
adapt to that and a metcon circuit
combining these different things is a
fantastic way to achieve that
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that would help me out immensely let me
know in the comments down below what
your favorite metabolic conditioning
workouts are and of course this is far
from a comprehensive list if it was it
would be you know hours and hours long
some other top picks that didn't quite
make the cut are the car push or truck
push or sled push fantastic exercise
another one that's a little bit tricky
to do jc santana did a brilliant video
on that on this channel i also love my
bag drag which i did on my recent
athletic exercises video this is one
where you crawl and drag a bag in fact
crawling in general can be better
metabolic conditioning than you might
think wrecking carries anything
involving a sandbag if you like this
kind of training it looks not just
aesthetics numbers on a few lifts but
all-round performance mobility strength
card or even brain training then you
might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
which comes with over two hours of video
instruction i'll leave a link to that
description down below thank you so much
for checking it out either way thank you
so much for watching this video guys
thanks again to crossraich for
sponsoring it and i'll see you next time
bye for now